hi i'm carrie mulligan and i'm here
today with buzzfeed to answer your
burning questions about promising young
woman
and this is full of spoilers so if you
haven't seen the film
switch off your phone put your computer
away and do not watch this video
what was it like working with emerald
fennel who wrote and directed the movie
a complete delight emeralds one of my
favorite people she's just hilarious
absolutely in command of the whole film
in the best way that gave a lot of us
freedom to kind of have fun on set so
yeah what's your favorite
behind-the-scenes memory from
filming promising young woman the uh
dinner table scene
probably with jennifer coolidge and
clancy brown and bo where emerald asked
us to improvise at the beginning of the
scene about what
you know she said just you know ask
jennifer what she does for a living
and so beau asked jennifer what she did
for a living and the first thing she
said was that she
had discovered late in life that she was
a very talented
fish tank interior designer which was
the kind of
moment where the entire crew just loses
it and i think i ruined that take pretty
quickly
and then the next time she said that she
was a roofer and the time after that she
said that she trained small animals to
detect carbon monoxide
and it just went on like that for about
an hour and i just couldn't do it i
don't know how comedians do it's just an
extraordinary super
special human skill what was it like to
film the scene
when ryan and cassie sing and dance to
paris hilton in the pharmacy
it was really stressful learning the
lines
to that song because everyone knows that
song but actually the lyrics are quite
difficult to learn so i think we were
sort of both joking about being like you
know a bit nervous about it and we got
on set
and emerald placed us on either side of
the aisle and said like okay guys
go for it bo immediately was just a
genius and started sort of picking up
cans of spam and popping packets of
chips and
was being so funny but i i just couldn't
i couldn't go there so i spent the first
two takes sort of glaring at him and
you know all in character but sort of
you know not really participating hugely
and then
emerald came over and said what are you
doing why aren't you you know singing
along
and i said i don't know em i just feel
like this is sort of you know cassie
wouldn't do that
and i was trying to hide behind my
character and she was like come on you
know when you're when you're in love you
just
you do crazy things it was great and it
bonded beau and i for life
promising young woman is a story about
sexual assault anger and also a really
beautiful female friendship between
cassie and nina what was it
like balancing all of those themes when
thinking about cassie's character arc
it's interesting i don't suppose it
really felt like my job to balance them
i think that's why i was so
lucky to have emerald she was it was
really her job she was the one who was
walking that tightrope i feel like my
role was just to play the writing um as
honestly as i
could and and writing does encompass all
of that stuff so
i think you know initially the focus for
me was nina
you know i couldn't really approach this
as something about revenge it felt for
me much more about
love and loyalty this movie is filled
with great comedians like bo burnham and
jennifer coolidge was there ever a
moment where you couldn't stop laughing
while trying to film a scene
well yeah i mean that dinner table scene
but also so many others
all with beau also with chris mintz
place
who i think the first time he sort of
kissed me on the nose i lost it
completely
the movie makes a point at calling out
the nice guy and how they can be equally
in the wrong was it intentional to cast
actors who are known for playing nice
guy roles like adam brodie sam
richardson max greenfield and chris
lowell yeah absolutely it was
um absolutely intentional on emerald's
behalf she wanted people that you felt
warmly towards and comfortable with i
don't think those
those scenes work if if you have
expectations
that somebody is going to be not a nice
guy i think if you see the guy who
ordinarily plays the villain um the
impact isn't really there and that was
particularly true for al monroe and i
think what's so powerful about chris
in that role and also in the writing is
that this is not somebody who thinks of
himself as being a bad guy
he doesn't want to go upstairs he
doesn't really want
you know he says to her like i don't
want to do anything i love my girlfriend
as an audience we we believed in these
guys until we saw
those scenes turn what was the
difference between cassie using red
versus black pen for the tally marks in
her notebook
that is for me and emerald to know and
the audience not to know for a minute
there ryan and cassie appear to have a
pretty great relationship do you think
cassie really loved ryan
yeah 100 i think she did i think it's
the easier path i think she really did
love him and i think
it's so it's sort of more heartbreaking
if the audience sees the life that she
could have had
you know if she chooses to but there's
just no way of getting past what she
discovers about him
so it's clear-cut from there the ending
is absolutely bonkers and it's
bittersweet for viewers what was your
reaction when you first read the script
it is bonkers the whole thing in that
you are constantly kind of wrong-footed
and i love that about it i think it's so
exciting refreshing to read a script
where
you don't know what's coming and you
keep having your expectations thrown off
and i definitely wasn't expecting the
ending but
i felt so strongly like emerald did that
it was important to tell the truth
and that that felt like the honest
ending to the film perhaps not the one
that we all
might have wanted um but that was the
truthful way to end the story
cassie has a lot of incredible outfits
in the movie do you have a favorite
i've requested to keep the nurses
costume just for posterity
i don't know i just love it it was just
hilarious
you